THIS ONE.
WORKING BACK IN DEEP.
STAAL ALONG THE BOARDS.
NUMBER 97 COMES ON THE ICE.
FOLIGNO'S CHANCE ACROSS THE
BLUE PAINT.
AND THE DEFENSIVE P
THAT WAY.
SENT IN THE SAME
SPOT URGEON.
HITS THE HOST.
NOW, A PILE UP.
THE PUCK IS S PAD TO
PREVENT THE RICOCHET TO PREVENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE WILD, ONE H
TROCHECK, AND NECAS!
HE HAMMERS LATE IN THE FIRST.
>> YEAH.
YOU WHO YOU'RE
TAKING.
>> YOU ARE ASKING ME.
AND
GETS IT TO SLAVIN.
HIS SHOT, PASS INTO AN AREA
SVE
THIS ONE.
CAROLINA IS CLOSE TO  BALLY
SPORTS  PERIOD.
>> LAUNCHING HIMSELF LEVEL TON
>> AND BUT SCORE. , HE
LEADS IT AND SEE
ALL SORTS OF ACTION TO GET TO
THE SECOND AND THIRD.
AND HE SCORES!
KIRILL KAPRIZOV HAD
SKATE.
ZUCCARELLO, AND KAPRIZOV GETS
INTO A VERY TIGHT SPACE.
LINE, AND WORKS ACROSS AND TO
THE MIDDLE OF THE RINK FIRST.
HOW ABOUT TERAVAINEN?
NOW NIEDERREITER FOR DOMI.
UP TOP.
SLAVIN.
PAINT.
HE CAN'T GET AWAY.
CHALLENGE.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE
CONCRETE BECAUSE IT'S Referee:
IS CONFIRMED.
WE HAVE NO GOAL.